jakka will Inc went from being a kid who
wanted to become a commando to spending
20 years in the u.s. Navy SEALs and
receiving the silver and Bronze Star
medals for his service in the Iraq war
he's an avid Brazilian jiu-jitsu
practitioner owns victory MMA and
fitness in San Diego and often trains
and corners professional fighters he's
also a successful podcaster author and
speaker need motivation watch top 10
with believe nation what's that belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and have you
believing in you here's my take on Jaco
willings top 10 rules to success vol 5
also if you want to know what Jaco and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below people want to
know how to stop the laziness and they
want to know how to stop the
procrastination
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take ownership on social media I see
this a lot guys will hit me up girls
will hit me up something went wrong with
a client I stepped in I took ownership
they thanked me problem solved
got it squared away I kid people are
surprised people are surprised that it
works people are surprised that it works
and again just to make sure everybody
knows it that alone doesn't work you
still have to problem solve the problem
without you cause with the client right
right you you you gave them what they
needed late or it's gonna be late and
now you say it's my fault that doesn't
mean that you don't need to get it to em
ASAP and make up some corrective
measures and lower the price to do
something so that it makes up for the
problem but the worst thing you can say
is well you specify exactly what you
wanted in the order and therefore we
couldn't get you what you wanted on time
okay we're never coming back for
business skin and we're angry this whole
time and I'm gonna short you money when
we pay you in anyways if I pay it off
the next time you get into a situation
and you write down are you techniques
the excuses and the reasons that you
come up with look at them and then
figure out how they were how those
things were actually your fault and or
how you could have prevented them
because a lot of times it's like here's
here's here's one hey boss we didn't get
the mission accomplished
because the weather rolled in and we
couldn't launch on the mission that's
that's the problem now we all know that
we don't control the weather so when you
will you write the problem down we
failed the mission because we didn't
control the weather
we can't control the weather that's why
we failed the mission that's my excuse
that's a that's a logical reason it
there's that's that's so that's a
legitimate excuse but don't use it what
you do is you say what could I have done
to have controlled the weather okay I
don't care okay wait I can't control the
weather what could I have done I could
have come up with a contingency plan I
could have come up we could have staged
in a better place so then you go to the
boss and you say look boss here's what
happened the weather went south really
bad
that was a problem but it's a problem
that I should have done a better job
taking care of what I should have done
was I should have had a contingency plan
I should have staged closer to the
target area that I could have taken
vehicles instead of helicopters that's
my fault from now on I will absolutely
have a secondary plan this won't happen
again
we can't control the weather but we can
control how we plan and how we execute
and this won't happen again there you go
so you take the most outrageous thing
that you know you can't control you
figure out a way to control it and you
take ownership of that thing and it is
gonna it's gonna make your life so much
better and by the way the next time you
have a mission and you plan that
contingency and you actually execute and
implement what you said you're gonna do
guess what you will accomplish the
mission
there's a whole part of ownership that
preempts the problem if you've got
someone that knows if I know that I can
make an excuse if I know that I can make
an excuse then guess what
I'm not gonna set things up properly if
I don't set things up properly mmm more
often or more often than the other way I
will fail to do execute what I'm
supposed to execute if you have an
excuse for the same same thing with you
as an individual human being if you as
an individual human being if you got
some excuses that you can throw out
there that you can say I had no control
over that then you know what you say
okay what are my contingency plans what
could I have planned differently
let's eliminate those excuses take
ownership of your freaking life rule
number two get up early the reason I
wake up at 4:30 in the morning cuz no
one else is awake yet so that gives me
the opportunity to do things that I need
to get done kind of selfishly for myself
and the big one in that category is
working out and it doesn't feel good at
4:30 when you get up but by the time 7
o'clock rolls around and you've already
worked out you've already gotten some
work done and you've got some time to
say goodbye to your kids before they go
to school it's infinitely better than
sleeping in until 6:45 and you get out
of bed now you're missed your kids going
to school or or whatever you you you're
not prepared for the day it's it's awful
something I'm sure you hear a lot is
4:30 like this either just can't fit
into my schedule or if I'm gonna be
realistic I'm probably not gonna wake up
it 4th
what do you tell people yeah and there's
people that work night shifts and
there's people that it's unhealthy for
them they can't fall sick no be healthy
get enough sleep but first of all wake
up at the same time every day and if you
pick that time and you start waking up
at the same time every day that's very
good for you it doesn't have to be 4:30
it could be 6:30 it could be 7 I don't
know what your personal schedule is but
find out a time pick it set it stick to
it and maintain that schedule and that's
gonna end up better for you
I recommend its earlier I recommend that
you go to bed earlier because what are
you doing at night most of the time most
the time at night you're not working on
anything super productive
you're just the winding down and
watching stupid YouTube videos or
surfing the internet reading clickbait
stories right don't do that instead go
to sleep and then wake up early rule
number 3 be yourself I was getting
interviewed the other day in some
interview and the guy said something
about like um you know it's impressive
how quickly you've built your brand
right and I looked at him and I said I'm
not a brand I'm a person I'm a person
what I'm doing is not what I'm doing
so that I can leverage people what I do
is just me and I'm just a person so if
you asked me if I would wear a rainbow
t-shirt
I wouldn't know I've asked you to wear
lots of stuff would you have you if and
if you asked me but but that's not
because of I'm trying to be something
it's because that's who I am
right and I have been I had one of my
bros who I hadn't seen in a while and he
we met at a little place we'd go to in
San Diego and I hadn't seen him in a
year and a half and he comes walking in
and he sees me and I'm wearing the same
thing that I always wear pair jeans a
victory black t-shirt and he walks in
and he see NFI it was wintertime and I
was wearing a flannel like a
whatever like a whoa New England yeah
like a New England but like cheap
whatever flannel with the quilt inside
of it yeah and um he sees me in like
when he sees me and this is kind of you
know after the books and the podcast and
he's in another seal so he suspect and
he sees me and I see his face and his
face like gets a happy when he sees me
and he and he comes over and like does
like a bro hug and he says probably
you're exactly the same and I was like
yeah man and he goes I knew it and like
that to me was the best compliment I'll
ever get is like okay no matter what
happens I'm not a brand I'm not doing
anything for you know any other reason
other than it's just me and that's just
just what I'm doing and if people are
cool with it man that's awesome I'm
still rule number four put others above
you if you're there and you're in a
leadership position or you're just in a
position you're in relationship whatever
and you're doing things for the team
you're trying to take care of the others
you're putting other people above you in
the end you're going to win and you're
gonna win way bigger than you could if
you were calling and scratching and
ripping things and bringing them back to
yourself the end that person that thinks
that thinks that they're doing the right
thing or things that they're doing
something good for themselves but what
they're really doing is taking things
from other people that person they might
get a couple tactical victories along
the way but in the end the person that
puts everyone else first is going to win
they are going to win so it's it's kind
of hypocritical because it's like in one
hand it's like no I don't care about
myself I'm not trying to improve I'm not
trying to trying to improve my station
in life but by doing that you will
improve your station in life and you
will improve your station in life beyond
anything that you could have done if
your goal
was to improve your station in life rule
number five be disciplined if you want
more freedom in your life you have to
have more discipline if you don't have
any discipline you'll end up with
absolutely no freedom you'll end up
being a slave to other people that boss
you around there's all kinds of problems
that can occur if you don't have
discipline in your life and the more
discipline you have the more freedom
you're gonna have so just that the
discipline of the sales will never it's
impossible to leave no it's possible to
leave there's there's retired seals all
over the place that are undisciplined
they've moved on and they don't care
about that anymore it's fine I don't
judge other people on what they're doing
like they're probably stoked to sleep in
and hang out with their kids and eat
breakfast in bed that's fine I don't
have anything gets that but for me I
want to get up and go rule number six
give trust how do I build trust with
someone the way I build trust with
people as I give them trust so if you're
working for me I say hey you know I want
you to do this mission Patrick come up
with a plan I'm showing you that I trust
what your plans gonna be now I'm gonna
I'm gonna make sure that your plan is
good I'm gonna review it but I'm gonna
give you a lot of autonomy
I'm gonna give you trust and when I give
you trust what's your reaction you think
yourself this guy trusts me yep and then
the way I build trust and reverses when
you make a mistake instead of me jumping
down your throat and hanging you out to
dry
instead I say okay you know what my
fault I should have given I should give
you a better direction here's what we do
next time so now you look at me you go
hey I screwed this thing up and jock
would still trust me I trust him and
that's how I build trust I give it you
give it
I give trust to build trust if I'm
really putting an effort but my plan may
be not the best plan
you're still gonna give me second
chances to work on and get better at it
I will micromanage you more I can't
trust you as much if we do a business
deal or we're in business I don't send
you out with the biggest client I've got
when you when I just met you and say hey
I trust you know I'll give you a little
client and I say hey go go go make this
happen and you come back and you say hey
look I did it I say great and you trust
me a little bit more
or maybe you screw that one up and I say
okay let me review what you do what
mistakes got made and you say oh well I
did this and okay we correct that but I
don't I don't come down hard on you
because I'm trying to build a
relationship with you if I come down
hard on you do you even want to work for
me do you want to be if I come down this
is pathetic you screwed this up this is
your fault you're looking for another
job tomorrow whereas if I say okay let's
look at what we can do better
and I'm building the trust but can you
know you might be very trustworthy for
many years and then all of a sudden you
go out and you do something on your hand
with a client you try and rip them off
or rip me off yeah I mean we're not
gonna have trust for me anymore
rule number seven make today count I
want to tell you something else and I
want to make this clear don't just
listen don't just listen do um I'm not
just talking so you know I'm not just
talking I'm doing and I don't want you
to just listen to put this information
to work make today count every day go
forward get aggressive and attack and
whether it's on the battlefield or on
the beat or in the factory or on the
farm or on the construction site or on
the website in the garage or in the
firehouse don't hesitate
step step forward and get after it
rule number eight start walking no
matter what you face no matter how bad
it is going to be when there is a
challenge and by a challenge I mean
anything in life any any challenge
anything that you're facing the only way
to overcome the challenges that you face
is to start walking
take that step every day no matter what
you are facing get up and start walking
rule number nine follow your passion
chuckle when did you know you wanted to
be a Navy SEAL well specifically the
SEAL team part of it wasn't until I
figured that out but when I was a little
tiny kid you know five six the only
thing I can remember was wanting to be
some kind of commando you knew that from
that point from from birth basic not was
it because pops or an uncle or grandpa
wasn't a military grandfather was in the
army and he was retired from the army
but that wasn't really it I just
instinctively was putting camouflage on
my face and carrying her on sticks and
carving him to look like machine guns
when I was a little kid for no reason so
that's just kind of are you from a big
family do you have siblings two sisters
two sisters an older one younger they
also go in a military or not at all
suggest you just me so from five years
old you know so when you won in high
school everybody's asking you what are
you gonna do after high school you knew
you're going in the military yep and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is work out I've
pretty much broken down my workouts into
four broad spectrums of working out I'm
gonna pull on one day I'm gonna push on
another day I'm gonna lift on the next
day and I'm going to squat on the final
day the fourth day and I just rotate
those things through and they're all
based fundamentally on some pretty basic
exercises for pullets based on pull-ups
doing pull-ups and you all you need to
do pull-ups is a set of rings or a
pull-up bar and you can handle that
workout the push is based on push-ups
and dips and all the exercises that are
associated with those types of movements
the lifts for me are lifting things from
the ground over my head and then finally
squat is based on squatting and there's
all different kinds of varieties of
squats you can do and I also include in
that sprinting and overhead squats back
squats front squats all those things get
incorporated in when I'm working a leg
day on top of those four on a regular
basis I want to train my my metabolic
conditioning so I want to do
sprinting and running and get my heart
rate up for very intense short periods
of time and then on top of that I do gut
exercises which is what we called in the
SEAL Teams when you're working your core
is the trendy term to call it or
sometimes you heard referred to as ABS
but I don't like those terms we call it
gut get something
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Jocko and how to be a great leader
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
in your business and if you're feeling
bold leave your replies in the comments
below here we go question number one
what can you do to make today count
number two are you willing to wake up
early as a test for the next week and
number three can you also commit to
working out consistently
[Music]
the immediate impression that everyone
would consider of me and I hear this all
the time
is that jakka would allow no slack
whatsoever no mercy on anything right
you're out of you're out of regulations
I'm gonna drop the hammer on you well
the fact the matter is that doesn't work
as a leader in the military you know
people wear patches on their uniforms
well the SEAL Teams has a reputation for
being very unprofessional don't really
know how to wear our uniforms well we
don't wear our uniforms a lot we have
mix and match gear we buy civilian gear
we wear that we just have a bad
reputation and one of the things that
once the war started and we started
getting these high speed camouflage
uniforms with Velcro everywhere well
guys started making their own patches
and the patches were you know some of
them were just cool you know whatever
some skull or a knife or whatever you
own bet you guys make their own patches
here's here's a typical one there's one
that guys would make that's a fun meter
and it would be a meter that's pegged
like okay we're maxed out on fun here
that's a typical kind of the type of
thing that people would make well I knew
from working with the conventional
forces that the way you appear in a
uniform is very important you know
you're in the army especially at an
Airborne Division I mean you wear the
same PT uniform you wear the same
uniform you a squared away all the time
that's the way it is yeah and I knew
that also soldiers and officers in in
the Army and Marines and Marine Corps
when they look at someone that's out of
uniform they look at that person system
Agee this guy can't even put on a
uniform right how am I gonna trust him
out on the battlefield that's just a
mindset that they have it's a good
mindset right if you don't have
attention to detail on that stuff that's
a problem well in SEAL Teams were real
slack about that I said to my guys look
we're not wearing patches no patches and
my two platoon commanders they said okay
you don't find no patches we won't wear
patches but they really wanted to wear
patches so behind my back they went and
they got patches made task unit bruiser
patches what they would do is if they
were going on an operation that I wasn't
going on when they'd roll out the wire
they'd make a call on the radio and say
patches on and they pull out their
patches and put their patches on they
basically disobeyed a direct order from
me would have been fine except for there
was a certain operation that they went
on there was an embedded photographer
and the pictures came back and I had all
the pictures and I see all my guys with
patches that I told not to wear you know
what I did I didn't do anything you
didn't bring it up I didn't bring it up
I realized number one we were
writing in a very hard environment where
troops were getting wounded and killed
every single day where were you at this
time we were Ramadi okay for me to focus
my leadership capital on something that
small was a complete waste of my
leadership capital number two I realized
that these guys that was a boost in
their morale that made them feel like a
tighter unit they gave these patches out
to army guys that was a big deal for
them and it meant a lot to him and so
for me to go in and rip that morale away
from him would have been a down step in
their vision of me and their respect for
me and it would have antagonized our
relationship I didn't come out and say
hey guys I saw the patches you're fine
to wear him and Lafe was talking about
this you know he thought I was just
gonna drop the hammer on him and I
didn't say anything and the guys
continue to do it and it was not a big
deal now they didn't wear any
inappropriate patches the patches that
they wore were all the same so it was
uniform but the answer to your question
which is probably the opposite of what a
lot of people think I'm gonna say is
like what are you gonna waste your
leadership capital on now the other side
of the spectrum if you get someone
that's doing something that's illegal
bets immoral that's that's strategic
that's gonna impact you strategically
yeah
I will not bail Jon on something that is
that important to me raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your good
suppose a man
if you like this video check out the
Jocko willing motivation video that I
made I think you're gonna enjoy the link
is right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there
[Music]